[Musique]
elle est signée Julien chaida bonjour
Julien bonjour nous commençons par les
États-Unis par la presse américaine par
les élections de mi-mandat ou la
campagne bat son plein avant le vote
prévu mardi prochain effectivement
Philippe il est intéressant de voir
comment la presse américaine couvre cet
événement regarder cette photo du New
York Times avec ces deux personnes
armées de fusils d'assaut et justement
cette inscription qu'on voit ici oui the
people en référence évidemment à la
Constitution américaine dans une seule
et même photo la violence des armes et
la démocratie et ce titre de l'éditorial
l'Amérique peut avoir ou la démocratie
ou la violence politique mais pas les
deux le journal s'intéresse évidemment
au climat de violence politique et
gangrène le pays depuis 5 ans entre des
informations et aussi énormément de
menaces physiques contre des élus
américains le New York Times parle d'un
scrutin à aurisc et vise directement la
mouvance de l'extrême droite adoratrice
je rappelle d'un certain Donald Trump je
vous invite aussi à regarder dans le
quotidien britannique de gardienne un
certain Donald Trump qui donc fait
planer son nombre sur sur cette élection
et qui serait d'ailleurs selon de garder
selon ce qu'on a aussi entendu dans les
derniers meeting qui serait deviné quoi
filmé et bien candidat à un nouveau
mandat pour la présidentielle de 2024 en
cas de victoire républicaine la semaine
prochaine un Donald Trump revancheur
nous explique le gardien et qui n'a
jamais vraiment reconnu sa défaite face
à Joe Biden il a dit qu'il est prêt à se
représenter il demande à ses partisans
d'être patient Julien quelle est la
position de Joe Biden dans cette
campagne et bien il enchaîne les
meetings il s'investit à fond pour
tenter de renverser la vapeur les
derniers sondages donnent les
républicains vainqueur mais le problème
c'est que la figure qui fait rêver
l'électorat démocrate n'est pas Joe
Biden mais regardez c'est son ancien
patron Barack Obama Barack Obama raconte
le Washington Post qui enchaîne les
meetings dans les états clés vous
pourrez se jouer justement cette
élection on le dit plus charismatique
plus énergique que son successeur
l'ancien président américain remplit ça
elle est accueilli je cite en rock-star
sur scène alors il voyait surtout pas
filmer une rivalité entre les deux
hommes l'objectif c'est de recueillir le
plus de voix possible autour de les
démocrates et si Barack Obama peut aider
alors pourquoi pas dit la Maison Blanche
on terminera ce chapitre américain par
un article très intéressant que j'ai
trouvé dans The Flines précis intitulée
et si finalement une victoire des
conservateurs arrangé Joe Biden c'est en
tout cas la thèse avancée par le journal
américain pour deux raisons la première
et bien c'est que traditionnellement et
bien les élections de mi-mandat sont
presque toujours défavorables au pouvoir
à la Maison Blanche une victoire
républicain ne serait donc pas vraiment
une surprise la seconde et bien c'est ça
qui est assez intéressant c'est qu'avec
une chambre et des représentants sous
contrôle républicain et bien cela
pourrait ouvrir la voie selon le journal
et des luttes internes dans le Parti
conservateur en vue des élections de
2024 on l'a dit Donald Trump devait être
devrait être candidat mais d'autres à
coup sûr voudront être sur la ligne de
départ de ce point effectivement rien
n'est gagné Julien chedda en revanche en
Israël tout a gagné pour Benyamine
Netanyahou il a remporté les élections
on peut dire de la politique israélienne
pourrait à nouveau redevenir Premier
ministre un retour sans précédent titre
le Jérusalem post avec cette question
qui gouvernera vraiment le pays le
leader de l'icône qu'on voit juste ici
ou bien ses partenaires d'extrême droite
car grâce à leur nombre de sièges ces
partenaires autrefois infréquentable et
bien se posent aujourd'hui en faisant
droit ce qui inquiète la presse
israélienne de gauche avec le quotidien
arrête si cette éditorial extrêmement
qui se dit plutôt inquiet que je
pourrais presque qualifier de
provocateur à ce titre provocateur c'est
officiel maintenant le fascisme est chez
nous en référence justement à cette
coalition d'extrême droite avec cette
influence grandissante à salam le
quotidien de ce qu'il appelle le
nationalisme sioniste religieux une
vision du monde qui n'est pas conforme
aux idéaux de la démocratie de la
démocratie pardon selon arrête arrête
qui publie un jour un petit dessin de
presse extrêmement
clair en fait car d'abord si l'extrême
droite est monté en Israël en Israël
d'après d'après arrête c'est bien c'est
la faute de la majorité sortante
majorité dominée par les centristes on
voit ici les deux hommes forts de cette
majorité avec Benny gonz d'un côté et
l'ancien Premier ministre sortant hier
la PID devant une guillotine une façon
dire que c'est leur faute et bien s'ils
n'ont pas réussi à convaincre les
électeurs de leur proposant pas sur la
durée une autre politique dans le pays
on change totalement de sujet Julien
chaidan nous sommes le 4 novembre 2022
cela fait exactement
s'entend qu'a été découverte la tombe de
celui qui est présenté dans votre
journal comme le premier influenceur de
l'histoire oui tout ça est très sérieux
vous reconnaîtrez non pas son visage
mais son sarcophage tout en Camon le
jeune pharaon dont la tombe a été
découverte il y a tout juste 100 ans
c'est-à-dire dans le magazine suisse qui
s'appelle l'illustray avec ce titre que
j'aime beaucoup tout en Camon un
influenceur vieux de 3000 ans le
magazine revient sur cette personnalité
finalement l'une des plus anciennes que
l'on connaisse dans l'histoire de
l'humanité le magazine revient sur son
très courte règne qui fascine toujours
autant on sait maintenant qu'il n'a rien
qu'environ 2 à 3 ans que sans la
découverte de cette tombe et bien il
serait peut-être tombé dans l'oubli
comparé à des règnes beaucoup plus
grandioses comme ceux de Ramsès II ou de
Néfertiti il y a 100 ans donc laissé le
mythe de Toutankhamon qui a influencé
évidemment des générations d'enfants et
des gyptologues merci beaucoup Julien
chedidas c'était la revue de presse que
vous je me suis fait vous pouvez
retrouver sur notre site France 24